so
uh as far as like
first films goes
i mean this is kind of the best
this is kind of it
yes
like how incredible is this whole thing
you think back to
when you auditioned and didn't really
know you know what it was for
what your life was like versus what
you're what you're doing like this week
oh my god
it was like so unreal and
wow
it can be pretty
um
what's the word um over overwhelm
overwhelming yes
yes
but yes everything's been great
and that's amazing yeah
and i
love your character and i love you and
simu together you gotta tell me like
we have to have more of her right like
there's gotta be plans that she's coming
back and doing more stuff
i mean yes like
the relationship between shanxi and
xiaoling in this movie is really
really intense
and it it starts with a lot of punches
and kicks
but
there's always love between siblings and
working with simu is really is really
really fun
and he's like a real brother to me
i mean yes
yeah i i got married on this on this
film i met my husband yang who's also
canadian uh he's one of the action
designers on our film and simu
took us to a disneyland trip
i mean it was really fun
i have to say i have an older brother
and he's never taken me to a disneyland
trip like an actual older brother so the
pressure's on now sandro if you're
watching
you gotta take me to disneyland bro come
on
go to the disneyland
i love that at the premiere your husband
had like your action figure in his
pocket i was thinking for your first
anniversary you got to somehow get an
action figure made of him
as a gift
oh there she is
yes
yes i got this action figure from simu
that's a that's a that's a present from
him it's it's
it's really fun to play with
yes absolutely now you must have been
just kind of a like a sponge on set
soaking up
every actors and every director a
dustin's experience ben kingsley's
experience tony lung's experience what
was it like for you to be able to share
the
set with them oh my god it's like
master class every day
i i'm telling you i literally took notes
when i when i talked to ben
and i asked him so many questions and i
just learned
so much
and tony his work ethic is amazing
and his performance i mean i could watch
his performance under a microscope
to see all those details
and michelle yo she's such
she's such
a unique soul
i really adore her and working with
aquafina wow
you cannot
how much fun we had
she's the coolest girl i've ever met
and finally you know one of the big
things i love in this movie that makes a
character so relatable is the karaoke
scenes they're just so much fun if you
were gonna have a karaoke partner
anyone from the avengers or the mcu that
was going to go out with you and sing
karaoke with you
who would it be
what song would you sing
i want to take ant-man because he's my
favorite
superhero and it's kind of
interesting i don't know because when he
shrinks i don't know if his voice got
small too so i want to know right
and that song i was saying if i got you
that's my go-to song
ah fantastic great choices all around
congratulations on this i love this
movie it was so fun talking to you all
the best thank you
bye